let's go next to bobby from
arizona hey
can you hear me yes i can how about you
bobby i'm well
um this is really exciting because i've
recently discovered you
og is like maybe six or so months before
the
last election so this is really exciting
is bobby short for roberta
no it's actually short just for just
bobby joe but oh that's a very common
question
thank you well glad to clarify uh
so my question was going to be in
regards to arizona's recent shift
to uh blue and young voters voting more
democratic or more independent i know
i've got a few people who don't
necessarily
say that they're they're a democrat but
they they don't
they're definitely not republican uh so
with the shift in blue i know a lot of
it
from what i've seen being in arizona
obviously
i think has to do with uh trump's you
know
decision to be uh distancing or be rude
to john mccain's uh
legend he's really big out here so
locally a lot of republicans are
there they really didn't like when when
trump said stuff like i prefer
war heroes who don't get captured and
stuff like that there was actually a big
sign
the day after the election where is uh
trump's uh
face and john mccain's and it was like
john mccain like
came back from heaven it's a big local
thing out here and then the other part
of it i think is
there's going to be more of a standing
for blue
uh just because of the young voters and
i was wondering if you had an opinion on
young voters turning blue
because i had an argument with someone
there's like no it's just because john
mccain i'm like it's
i don't think it is though no i think
it's more but so there's there's two
different things there's
are there more young people and the
young people are just more on the left
or are you saying that there are
young people voting in arizona that used
to vote republican now or and now are
voting for democrats
so i know personally that's my case the
latter so i grew up in a
with uh with boomer parents and they
were very republican and that's all that
was fed
republican rhetoric so i had as soon as
i became older and started actually
interacting with people
um i did end up learning more about the
world and then realized well that's not
really
not fair but not the right way that i
feel like should be done
yeah so more independent media more uh
things on youtube your show i discovered
and
i realized more and more about things
that i wanted versus what my parents
wanted
right so i know personally that was my
decision but yeah i mean
anecdotally there's i know of a lot of
that going on i know people who voted
for joe biden in arizona who essentially
had never voted for a democrat at the
national level since they became old
enough to vote
it's of course anecdotal but it's
interesting that you're observing that
in arizona because
the p i know lots of people who are on
the left and didn't vote
and then they went out and voted for
biden in order to remove trump in
november but those are people who were
always on the left
in arizona specifically i know people
that are exactly what you're
saying you yourself are which is they
actually used to vote for republicans
and then they voted for joe biden so
i don't know what to make of it these
are it's just anecdotes but obviously it
bodes well
for the left in arizona yeah no i think
there's going to be more of a blue shift
and i don't think it's just like a
one-time thing personally let's hope
let's hope
now how are things going on mask-wise
are people because i know that
arizona has been some describe it as a
coveted hellscape what
how is it feeling there right now uh it
depends on the areas like if you go
to uh like north uh like the richer
areas
it's much more relaxed and then more
i think a lot of businesses are taking
more of the ownership on
the requirement so it just really
depends on the areas that you go to i
think it's a lot of dependent on
uh whether or not you say anything like
i had gone to the store and i asked uh
there's people without math and i asked
associated i was like hey
do something and they they did but it's
one of those situations where it just
it's going to take as a group as a
society i feel like to put the pressure
because i think more people will fold in
that situation i think you're right and
i mean listen hopefully
we can vaccinate quickly enough that
this becomes a non-issue because some
people are just not going to wear masks
yeah i'm looking forward to when i'm
available i'm in the younger category
and i'm
i'm relatively healthy i'm staying more
isolated i work from home so
i'm willing to wait until it's available
for my group than
just rushing in but i do know that my
husband works in the grocery and they
just opened it up in arizona
for grocery workers to get it so i'm
excited to have him
lots of states even in advance of may 1
are saying
18 plus 16 plus can get vaccinated so
let's let's hope so all right thanks
bobby for the call
oh thank you all right bobby from
arizona
very very good caller one of our
sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create
out of thin air it'll even autofill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number you're keeping your identity
private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at privacy.com
slash pacman